What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity and welcome to another episode
of Challenge Pongfinity.
This is the series where YOU challenge US
with your craziest ideas related to table
tennis.
We will go through all of your comments, pick
the most creative ones and make a video out
of them.
If your idea gets picked, we will feature
it and give it a shout out.
So make sure to leave your ideas in the comments
below!
Adult Cow wants us to play a 2 min long rally
with the handle of the racket.
We are going to give it 3 tries.
Let's see how it goes.
On our last episode of Challenge Pongfiity
we did 5 consecutive around the net shots.
Now Matija Sirovec wants us to do 20.
So, let's do it!
Basic Breik wants us to play a rally with
only 1 racket.
That means we will throw the racket to each
other
and we will see how many shots we can do.
Let's go!
Thanks for watching guys!
If you enjoyed the video leave it a thumbs
up and let's see if we can reach 2.000 likes
with this video.
If you are new to the channel, subscribe right
here
and watch the previous episodes here!
Until next time!
With only 1 racket...